two days before October it's not quite
October but this is a very Halloween is
movie I'm reviewing so I feel like I
should do the Halloween
inro I'm going
[Music]
to so saw X is the 10th Saw movie that
has an X in the title because it's way
cooler to say x than 10 this has Tobin
Bell returning as John Kramer it's not
exactly a prequal best I can figure
given the information that I got in the
movie it takes place after one but
before two so it's saw 1.5 so John
Kramer and Amanda are supposed to be
about 19 years younger than they look in
the film but it is what it is point is
after John Kramer's Bleak cancer
prognosis he runs across his information
that leads to this amazing procedure
that could save his life turns out well
that was one sketchy van ride
later and a lot of this doesn't quite
feel right kind of vibe turns out John
Kramer's just out a lot of money however
they just scammed jigsaw so here we go
which is a really cool take for bringing
saw back I mean we've seen it get
personal for jigsaw in the past but this
was a much more personal John Kramer
chapter in the Mythos of Saw and you
feel that in the film it's not just the
recordings and then these people have to
deal with these torture devices no John
Kramer does have the recordings but he's
also there giving them the pep talk he's
in the warehouse with them he wants to
see them pass or fail he wants to see
the decisions they make most of all he
wants to see them tortured we all want
to see that so how are the traps in this
film the traps were fun as always I mean
it's saw fun there are a couple of the
traps that have I guess we'll say holes
in the logic but you can do the mental
gymnastics of work around it but being
real about it jigsaw John Kramer being
the protagonist of the film I just
thought was a cool take on it usually
it's jigsaw but there's some other
protagonist navigating the situation
this was his film and we're rooting for
him as oppose one of the reasons I've
always liked JN Kramer as a character
one of the reasons he's always stood out
to me is he's always had a moral code
his tactics are absolutely brutal but
he's a man with a code and I can respect
that but sawx expands on that you get a
deeper more personal look of that side
of him you see how he can feel bad for
someone or he'll fight for the safety of
an innocent life this is the first Saw
movie in a very long time that added
real depth to John Kramer's character in
that respect but more importantly you
need to find people to be in these
jigsaw traps that are far worse than
jigsaw himself and boy they do let's
face it when jigsaw is picking people
there can be a bit of a range like I
want to play a game for years you've
been embezzling money you falsified
evidence you framed someone for a crime
they didn't commit for decades you've
boasted that you've beaten Contra though
you've never been able to do it without
the Konami Code folks in the traps in
this movie are some trash garbage
human beings they are scamming
terminally ill people I've never wished
for people to fail jigsaw tra so much in
my life but not all things being equal
not all people being equally involved
there is some complexity in here too
like there's one person in particular
where it's like was she as bad as the
others or was she in a bad spot with
shny Smith returning as Amanda jigsaws
Apprentice I like the dynamic there iel
like sawx had a lot more buildup than a
lot of other Saw movies did they take
about the first 40 minutes or so really
crafting this situation and this
betrayal that John Kramer goes through
they really want you to understand why
he's doing what he's doing and root for
him not a bad thing but worth mentioning
in a world where there's probably saw
fans out there that want to see
everybody in the room at the beginning
of the movie and they're in the Saw
traps and let's go Saw traps this has
more buildup leading up to that granted
they do have a couple of Saw traps
leading up to that main event like any
Pay-Per-View fight you know you got the
little fights leading up to the main
event is how it goes I appreciate this
film taking its time to craft the plot
also recognizing that people need
appetizer so here are a couple of Saw
traps along the way if you you haven't
been a fan of saw before if it hasn't
been your thing it's probably not going
to win you over but if you're a saw
Super Fan out there I think you'll enjoy
it I thought it was a great return to
form and it reminded me why there was
this block of time in which I really
enjoyed the Saw movie they were
intermittent in quality hit or miss you
might call them but what was good about
them when they were good is found in
sawx I had myself a bloody good time no
alcohol required all right so sawx have
you seen it what did you think about it
or if you're feeling up to it if you
want to rank the saw films comment
section is there for you to do so might
need a refresher before doing that
I might need a refresher of the Saw
movies but whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see
[Music]
my for years you've been lying to your
friends about cilantro saying it tastes
like soap